is how exactly should you or a Muslim
seek there are guidelines given in thei
how we should seek for it's mentioned
Abu da volume number one in the book of
Salah Hadith number 1370 AB pleased with
him he said that we used to
fast along with the messenger of Allah
and he never woke up up for pray in the
night except on the seven last remaining
nights where we prayed till 13 of the
night and on the sixth remaining night
he did not wake us up and again on the
fifth remaining night he woke us up and
we prayed till half the night and when
the prophet was about to go he asked
that why don't you pray with us the full
night till morning so the prophet said
that anyone who prays till the Imam
prays that is as though he has prayed
for the full
night and further it's mentioned in s
bukari Vol number three in the book of
superiority of
seeking Hadith number
2014 that anyone who
prays in the night
of with sincere faith and seeking
Allah's reward all his past sins will be
forgiven and it's mentioned in
Hadith number
3512 the with her the wife of the
Prophet she asked the messenger of Allah
subhana tala that what if I find what
should I
do so the prophet replied that you
should do Dua and
supplicate to Allah subhana wa taala
saying that oh Allah subhah wa ta'ala
you are most forgiving
and you love forgiveness therefore
forgive me it's mentioned
inkari volume number three in the book
of fasting Hadith number
2024 that the Beloved Prophet M wasallam
during the last 10 days of Ramadan he
used to tighten his waist belt that
means work harder and abstain from
relationship with the wife and he used
to stand in prayers in the last 10
nights and used to wake up his family
it's further mentioned in s
Muslim number two in the book of fasting
Hadith number
2644 that Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him in the last 10 nights of Ramadan is
to exert himself more and worship Allah
more pray more and to in the last 10
nights so this is the way how a Muslim
should seek